[Music]
[Applause]
hello and welcome to fat man on Batman I
yeah
all by myself in my house because
because yeah Kevin is out in the world
hey hey everybody
again what's going on hello hello yeah
my name is Mark Bernardi and this is fat
man I'm Batman
this is not the scum and villainy can t
know because keV is somewhere in the
world doing camp [ __ ] my glass is weird
are they are they glaring too much a
little fix that so yeah so what we're
gonna do today is is a bit of a Q&A and
you know every now and again I'll do
that on Twitter and just say hey for now
we're on to questions and answers should
send questions but now [ __ ] it let's do
it on video let's do it Instagram let's
do it live you know what the kids [ __ ]
do it let's kill it so so yeah man I am
ready to answer any and all of the above
questions you may or may not have say
yeah man
whenever you guys are ready far away
before that I will give you a tiny tour
of my office which is probably a mess
always definitely a mess cuz I'm a bit
of a messy guy but yeah so this is uh I
got my hey kids comma crack I got a
bunch of [ __ ] comics back there I got
what's this over here
so my ink black the thing Hey okay there
was a question back there let's see
since there's no Michael in the Disney
would bring back James Gunn who would
you like to see direct guardians against
volume 3 I am still going to stick with
James Gunn I think they I think they
might bring him back I think there's
definitely a world in which the you know
and it's totally possible that they can
realize oh yeah we made it we made a
mistake this was a bad call we're going
to recorrect we made if not that
um I think there is a world in which the
Russos sort of jump in I don't think
they're committed to anything Marvel was
posted infinity war 2 and I think
directed the Guardians before they know
the world and they can definitely
deliver a movie so I think that is
definitely definitely possible let's see
that was a question from Jay hill 1181
Colleen and TV Land wants to know when
we are getting more genius
the way it's looking I think it's going
to be mmm
spring of next year maybe possibly
hopefully Adam Freeman and I my
co-writer are ready to go we know the
story we're gonna tell we know where
everything is gonna go potentially where
everything wraps up so I think if we can
get the green light from our publisher
we're gonna start writing and if we
start writing we can be done in a couple
of months and have an artist ready to
rumble and so yeah I think spring spring
is optimistic late spring like May is
optimistic but possible probably more
like summer but yeah I don't know maybe
let's see the Rob Espinosa Muslim how
many episodes in the first season Castle
Rock that is 10/10 Emma soaks my episode
the one that my name is on that I
co-wrote with a guy named Vinnie Wilhelm
as episode six so that is in two weeks
all the shit's in two weeks two weeks
let's see Jay Gonzalez wants to know
what's the process in the writing room
for Castle Rock wow that is a big
question that is a long question because
that the writing room itself is uh is a
very you Steve um product placement on
the back there for the Highwaymen yeah
you know just I'm always I'm always on
the money it is a long process we were
in the room for four months four and a
half months I think and the process in
any registry basically it's a it's a big
to little process
it's a here's the big story we're
telling a season wide story
and you decide right we're happy with
where we're gonna start and where we're
gonna end and here's him selfie one in
the middle then you break it down into
episodes if there's 10 episodes in
season so I know what happens in these
one of those 10 episodes where how are
we going to begin to plant the the
signposts and the trail guides along
that way that helped us get to that end
point and then from episode you go into
scenes and then it's alright what are
the 40 scenes that are in this episode
of TV what happens in between the scenes
who's in those scenes what is the plot
energy we're trying to convey what is
the emotional energy we're trying to
drive well as the character evolution
we're trying to to begin to explore and
from there it'll go off to a writer
because they in that room everybody
who's on the staff I written the writer
said is in that room at the same time
and once you get down to the same level
and everybody agrees with everything
that's happening everybody's had their
chance to to give notes and to
contribute then the individual right of
that episode goes off and writes the
outline based on that scene breakdown
and then what will happen after that is
that guy goes off and writes a script
and then that script after a couple of
weeks gets live it back to the room we
all read it we all give notes and then
it is out of our hands then it goes off
into the production giant locomotive
which which will kill itself to make a
to make a show happen so that is that is
the largest that is that is the shortest
way to explain precisely how a writers
room works let's see
gyro captain 94 wants to know what is
one movie I think should be remade a
single movie that I think has some value
it does I mean I don't hate it when we
make a good movie because what's the
point if it's a good movie it's a good
movie why why monkey buy something
that's great but it would have to be a
movie that has some inherent quality
that makes it worth making as a movie I
thought they somehow got wrong the first
time
what movie I think should be remain see
if we were in the cantina now this would
be the time where Kevin answers first
and I think of something and then I I
have those four minutes to be like oh
[ __ ] that's it I know you should do but
I don't quite have the blue on the top
of my head it's funny I was about to say
Excalibur because I honestly think that
since Excalibur there hasn't been a
great King Arthur movie which is weird I
think because it's such a a bulletproof
story and and it resonates with a bunch
of people and they've tried oh lord have
they tried but uh but nothing has quite
come close to Excalibur which itself
isn't even like a perfect movie but but
there's a lot to recommend it's it's a
it is an arthouse film that also happens
to have blood of godson and nudity and
charms of making [ __ ] but uh I liked
King Arthur a legend with a sword but
not quite enough so so yeah uh yeah I'll
go Excalibur cuz why not
the Peter Sherlock wants to know if I
would ever collaborate with keV on a
project
yes and I cannot say any more than that
let's see
Michael Bookman would you want Phil
Coulson to have a twin brother who can
save his life and FBI agent Mike Casper
that is not bad especially given that
I'm watching The West Wing is on my TV
over there right now I just choose to
think that Mike Casper and Phil Coulson
are the same people and may have been
existing like you know that that was
Phil Coulson's first job he's an FBI
agent he worked for you know ended up
interfacing with president Bartlet and
president Bartlet clearly is the
president in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and that's just that's the web
I don't so actually this
Charlie young is the president in the in
the Marvel Cinematic Universe because
that would be badass have I watched
let's see
any SS have I watched Castle Rock so far
and how do I feel about it I have
watched it so far I had seen the pilot
before it dropped on Hulu I saw a little
bit of the third episode before it
dropped and I saw very early cut of the
sixth episode which is when I wrote but
I've been watching week by week just as
you that because I haven't seen the
finished version of a lot of those
things so yeah I have been watching it
and I feel it's it's a weird thing it's
it's it's really odd given that I
there's the stuff that I know we wrote
in the show like on the scripts
especially at this stage and seeing how
those things like seeing what stayed and
what changed and things change all the
time after script I mean there's there's
stuff with like the actors when the
actors get involved and then the
production gets involved and you know
what's working on the stage one isn't
what resources you have to deliver and
don't and then when you get into post
and you see actually alright well we
shot all this and how does it stitch
together this it all makes sense and all
of that stuff changes it is it is a it's
a living document until the the audience
gets to see it so it is it is a weird
experience sort of revisiting the things
that I know we did like memory compact
compared with reality is always an odd
thing and that's kind of what this feels
like but it's I think I think it's a
pretty strong show I'm just saying I
mean I am a hundred percent biased but I
think that I think I think we maybe got
there maybe yeah we'll see who would
play me in my life story
hmm Idris Elba because why the hell not
aim high that was a question for mr.
Kevin Conroy
let's see everywhere double-o one asks
would love your thoughts on the end of
the Skywalker saga well I don't think I
mean we definitely don't know that we're
at the end of the Skywalker saga we
don't know that that what what kind of
Ren tells Rey is true that her parents
were nobody from nowhere from nothing I
think I I mean I think we definitely
close the chapter on the Skywalker saga
and I think that's a good thing because
as as much as I love Star Wars and
Empire and Return of the Jedi as much as
I love Star Wars itself it has always
felt very insular to me that it is just
the story of this one family and there
have to be other stories under these
particular twin sons so so yeah I'm
hoping there's more I'm hoping that that
the end of the Skywalk Assad it doesn't
mean the end of Star Wars I mean there's
no way that it does but show me what the
rest of this world looks like you know I
mean that's one of the reasons I was
kind of excited about wrote one in that
it didn't have anything to do really
until the last five minutes with the
Skywalker's at all it just what's
another story in this world what are
other people who live in a galaxy far
far away a long time ago like so yeah I
hope I hope we get there and you know I
know we get there given that as far as
we know most of the Skywalker's we know
are dead so yeah although kylo Ren is a
Skywalker so what anyway
the William green wants to know Huey and
Kent will come to Seattle for a life fat
men anytime soon there's nothing on the
books for Seattle but we would love to
go or at least I would love to go I
think ever like Seattle so why would he
not love to go but that always comes
down to you know we got to get booked
like somebody's got to decide that they
want to you know either a convention or
a venue it needs to say hey we think we
can make money selling tickets for a fat
man I'm Batman
let's pay these guys their pay those men
their mommy and I mean we'll come we I
don't think we've said no to any offer
that's
down the pike so it's gotta convince
your local purveyor of Awesomeness to uh
to ask us let's see the Peter Sherlock
what superhero property that hasn't been
done yet would you like to see slash
work on well let's see let me look at my
giant wall of comic books here and
honestly man I would love to write on a
sandman TV show sad man was in in a very
real way one of the two books it was it
was the it was the book that I loved the
most when it first came out and when I
when I read it in singles and floppies
there was something about that story
that just that that spoke to me as a
writer especially cuz I was a journalist
at the time I was like training towards
journalism and it unlocked a lot of
things for me in the just the
possibilities of what stories could do
you know both in comics and anywhere
else just you know you Neil Gaiman built
for himself the universe in which he
could tell any story he wanted to tell
and and the freedom to just decide this
month I want to talk about an African
dream goddess and this month I want to
talk about a transgender teen in New
York and this month I want to talk about
William Shakespeare and this month I
want to talk about the end of time like
all of those things could live within
the universe that he built so being able
to play in that universe being able to
have the latitude and the freedom to to
go anywhere your mind might take you
that would be pretty badass that'd be
pretty badass let's see um lethal Monte
Cristo wants to since I don't know a lot
about Stephen King's books while I still
enjoy Castle Rock absolutely it was a
series designed to both appeal to the
people who are deep Stephen King fans as
well as people who never read a Stephen
King book before little was sort of
heard about it and I don't like to read
or whatever but the idea was to to tell
a story that was in the key of Stephen
King
so less a cover
and more like oh here's an unearthed
song that Stephen King wrote that nobody
ever heard before and so it'll feel like
king and it'll operate like king and
it'll pay off like king without being
you know a check the boxes of Easter
eggs for nothing
let me see but but found under put the
bump the bump um let's see Jeff man oh
five wants to know what I'd rather see
Snyder's kind of Justice League or Lord
Miller's cut of solo I I would rather
see Lord and Miller's cut of solo and
that is simply because Snyder left
Justice League because of tragedy which
is you know awful and my heart still
goes out to him for that but the the
decision for him to leave was not one
over creative differences it was one
over you know Bend with and in his heart
not being in it and and an artist's
incapacity to make art and that felt
like it was a self-motivated decision
whereas Lord Miller were fired and so I
kind of want to see what they were fired
for like how and I and I also want to
hear what their initial pitchford for
solo was like what was the thing that
made Kathleen Kennedy so excitedly ya
know give it to those guys I want to
hear what that pitch was and I see what
they shot and see what the
powers-that-be felt was so egregious
that they had to get fired for it which
is different than the miss nutter cut so
yeah that's where I go that's that's
kind of where I want to be let's see
Adam parks 94 which genre film would
make the best adaptation on a stage
production my man
I want here's my dream my dream of all
James have no Broadway experience I've
no theatrical experience I've never I've
never written exert stage left on a page
but my dream of all dreams if I ever get
a billion dollars and says what would
you like to do I want to do a Flash
Gordon Broadway musical because that
[ __ ] is crazy
that [ __ ] is so staged bound like you
look
that movie everything is just like
glistening stages and amend and shiny
floors and shimmering sheets and the
most amazing Queen songs in the world
and the special effects of shitty and
that's fine but that that feels like if
there's a one-to-one translation between
like Broadway stage musical and movie
that for me is the closest thing and
it's so Daffy and silly and stupid but I
love it to death but I think that that
like that that one to one of you know
can you can you replicate the feeling of
watching that movie on a stage hell yeah
like can you get just giant screeching
guitars in there hell yes
like I would oh yeah man for sure would
do it in a heartbeat Bruce fretts who I
worked with it until the wiggly he's was
curtain graduating me on ooh he wants my
episode of Castle Rock we thank you I
haven't seen again so you're the only
one a sex Menace wants to know if I'm
working on any new podcast ideas not
really well that's also not true I I am
still trying Tricia Helfer and I are
still trying to make this Battlestar
Galactica at work and it's and it's not
out of lack of enthusiasm or desire like
we both still want to do it but it's
working out the kinks with the podcast
partner who still seems to want to do it
so we're not dealing with contracts and
contracts or the slows things in the
world so yeah I'm hoping that that will
happen there there had been a slight
desire on my part I realized the other
day and by the other day me like four
months ago that I have not seen nearly
as many Akira Kurosawa movies as I feel
like I should given that he is 100% one
of the 10 greatest directors to have
ever worked in anywhere like in the
history of cinema
he is easily top 10 maybe even top 5 and
I have only really seen four out of the
50 some-odd movies he's made and I feel
bad for that
so I was thinking that maybe there's
some kind of like you know just watching
a kira podcast in which I you know
watching the makita Kurosawa movie every
week and just talk about it I don't know
is that something you think people would
care about you tell me Essex Menace
would you would you would you listen to
that even better would you pay to listen
to that
if Ghostbuster oh 209 if I start a man
back to the future style movie what song
would I perform at the under the sea
dance Wow bring the noise by Public
Enemy how low can you go death row water
brother not once again back is the
incredible rhyme animal yet killer both
be public enemy number one father said
freeze have I got numb I could keep
going I'm not gonna Robert Jackson 1990
will I try to get back into Gotham nah
you know because he was the problem
there are at any given time 400 TV shows
that I haven't seen yet there's 75 of
them that I've been told are amazing and
you need to ugh I have never I'll admit
it here right now I will admit publicly
I've never seen Breaking Bad I saw the
pilot and that's it
I like the pilot but for whatever reason
did not keep watching if I it's as I've
been told the greatest show to ever
exist on television I cannot in good
conscience not watch Breaking Bad but
return to Gotham which I watched your
seasons of and didn't really like you
know it's the and I get it that
sometimes shows get better sometimes
shows you fall over time and sometimes
you know they're they're doing good work
that nobody might be watching
I am also for some reason still watching
agents of shield why because it did get
better but I never stopped watching it I
just don't I feel like once I dig into
something and I'm watching it and then
for whatever reason I it or don't
respond to it or it loses me jumping
back into
that thing almost never happens that's
just me some people might absolutely be
like no I do know you told me was good
so I checked back in and you're right 43
episodes later it paid off
I don't personally I don't have that
time
or that desire to you know there's this
great quote from Christopher Eccleston
when he talked about we wanted to come
back for Doctor Who or whether we'd come
back for Doctor Who for the 50th
anniversary and he said something like I
never walk in the same river twice which
you know also feels like artsy [ __ ]
but there are some validity there that
you know he did that thing he gave it
his all he thought he did good work and
so move on move on mr. Kevin Conroy who
was my favorite Star Wars character han
Solo
yeah it's Han Solo I while I also I
quite liked Lando Calrissian he is less
a character for me because I don't
especially in in the in Empire and
return the Jedi I don't really know I
mean I know what he wants he wants to
just be left alone to run best Ben Cloud
City and he wants to like a little bit
more power and a little bit more money
but it's it's still a little bit of the
things that drive him don't seem to
impact or dovetail with what Star Wars
is about um and you know I think they
try to help tweak that a little bit with
solo and they made a more interesting
but hey maybe JJ has some brilliant
ideas and what Lando has been doing for
the last 40 years but no han Solo is my
jam let's see but um see properly one
wants to know if we're taking from the
Robert Ludlum books for Treadstone we
are a much as Castle Rock is a you know
a a story in the spirit of King lesson
adaptation of actual King I think that
in the same with Treadstone we are we
are not pulling directly from the Ludlum
books but the idea is for it to feel
like a Ludlum book if that helps
let's see another question from mr.
Kevin Connolly one of my thoughts on the
Buffy reboot I my one thought is I hope
it's not a reboot because they're the
it's built into the story like into
every generation a slayer must come so
we're just in a new generation you know
I don't I don't necessarily want this
character to be named Buffy because you
know there is a Buffy the Vampire Slayer
we saw Buffy the Vampire Slayer and and
so I think that just telling the next
chapter in that story is for me more
interesting if for no other reason so
that in season three Alyson Hannigan can
show up as willow and that will make
sense you know like I I want a new cast
of characters in that world with that
Sensibility but like why would you cut
yourself off from the joy in the wonder
of oh [ __ ] season 5 is about Giles
that's cool why would it not be about
Giles that's what I'm here for so yeah
like it I have no intelligence beyond
they're making more Buffy whether it's
new Buffy or same old Buffy or just
different thing you know there's more
than one Slayer so let's do more than
one Slayer let's see Michael Bookman
wants to know as a writer editor reading
other people's work what is my biggest
Grammer pet peeve you know like it's I'm
I am the worst editor in that I find it
really hard to articulate why a thing
I'm reading is wrong beyond the fact
that I know that it's wrong which pisses
my son off to no end when he gives me
he's only some work to read and I'm just
like that's not right it's like I don't
I can't remember what a split infinitive
is or a untangling participle which
sounds way dirtier than it is it's just
like I look at it and I can sense that
it's not doing what it's supposed to do
or it's not is that as clear as it
should be clarity is my biggest pet
peeve do not be overly complicated or or
flowery or I just make your
point known writing is about
communication and if you are trying to
communicate a photo and idea to somebody
make it so that it's unmistakable what
your intent was and what the content
what the data you're trying to pass on
is the more you try for it for not
clarity the the less it's effective is
communication and that's why you hear
let's see the mooks Comics wants to know
what British TV shows float my boat I
was a fan of Torchwood especially
children of Earth I like Luther quite a
bit
I am a ride-or-die hardcore for the
great british bacon show let's see mi5 I
liked ultraviolet I really liked back in
the day Doctor Who I am of a fan yeah
like I don't I don't grind super deep on
British TV you know killing Eve was
pretty fantastic but you know when I
when I see it I tend to like what I see
but I don't go like crazy crazy deep in
it
let's see Papa Papa spends for 17
any word on when me and Kev are gonna
sit down to do a commentary track on the
dark night fingers crossed hopefully
soon soon would be amazing Rio cmj what
episode are you named writer I was from
the Mets of Castle Rock episode 6 I
believe the episode is still called
filter the real dork night were you born
franchised loyalist before coming on
board the show how has that V change
from before to current I was a born fan
for sure I mean it was part of my
interview hey did you watch the Bourne
movies yes did you like the brothers yes
ok check I think the the first three are
still the best three I think Bourne
Legacy loses some steam a little bit
like it's it's it does that thing where
you're answering questions the audience
isn't asking and so it's a tricky line
between
there's a tricky line between deepening
the understanding of the world that
you're playing in and giving too much
information like I don't need medic
lorian's I've never needed Minnick lines
that is not why I tuned up for Star Wars
science not why I'm there not a question
I wanted answers to magic was still the
best explanation for why things work in
stores universe
I think Jason Bourne the most recent one
is fine but it doesn't have you know
after a while the question of Who am I
and why did they do to me for the same
character doesn't sustain itself and
then just coming up with new questions
for the same character set of answers
like you know some stories need ends so
I don't I don't it is not my favorite of
the five at this point but I'm still a
big fan let's see
Jed Minh 2488 if genius were to be
adapted what would be the best format
for it I feel like I mean it's it's a
serial story it is a serial story that
has an ending when there was just the
first volume siege I that's a movie
that's totally a movie like that but I
see what the two-hour movie version of
that looks like but because it's a comic
book because we now have two cycles and
because we've done some of the work of
thinking about where it could go later
on I kind of feel like it's best
destinies as a TV show so yeah fingers
crossed we get to you get to make that
happen
X Jessica faith X agrees with an earlier
dude things I should do voice acting I
have done so far one ever voice role and
it was for it was for Kevin it was for
the super groovy chainsaw Bob super
goofy cartoon movie I was the I was the
mayor of
was it read back maybe no no it was the
mayor of Asbury Park I think but hey I
would love to that sounds super duper
easy which I know it's not I am sure
that suddenly like the voice actor can
you be like [ __ ] you man this is hard
goddamn work which I understand by but
you know I can work on my sweatpants
which yeah
Domino EEP what's my favorite sports
team ah let's say New York Giants for
football mm I don't really have a
favorite basketball team because the
Knicks that broken my heart just enough
times baseball I'm a New Yorker so I
have to go Yankee so that my grandfather
was Mets and so that always made it
weird
hockey and AH black dude and is there
any other [ __ ] support the team sport
that I watch not especially not
especially
so yeah there you go blah blah blah blah
blah blah boom - PPP - beeping another
question from Jessica faith since
working on Castle Rock have you visited
any of Stephen King's work for
inspiration or do we like to stay away
from a source material the first couple
of weeks in the Castle Rock room were
all research we all like picked a book
and read a book and then brought back to
the group what we thought about that
book what was actionable and usable and
an inspirational it was a lot of the
early work in that room was about
figuring out what makes Stephen King
tick you know like getting under the
hood and dissecting and realize that oh
this is why people respond to Stephen
King books I'm not gonna give away that
special sauce because hopefully I'll go
back for season two but I got to use
that but yeah we we definitely you know
swam in the world of Stephen King and
and you know be there's glory and Wonder
and try to squeeze from that essence out
onto the page miss Danny Fernandez the
amazing Danny Fernandes I've done so
much what is something you haven't done
yet that you hope to accomplish
what makes you excited I am still
committed to this idea of writing and
directing a future film before I turn 50
years old
time is burning on me I'm 46 so that
leaves me a couple of years but those
things can take time but I still that is
that is still a dream a dream I have
that someday I will be able to make that
happen
things seem to be getting in the way
amazing things wonderful things that are
taking time away from pursuing that
because it turns out that part of the
joy of living the dream is that the
dream gets in the way of other dreams so
yeah but I still fingers crossed want to
get that done I really would like to
Ghostbuster Oh 209 again what's one of
your proudest moments being a dad it's
you know the the moments that I have the
the proud moments that I have are not
ones of like hey you want a medal
because you know I'm not that guy like
achievement is not the thing that makes
me go so it's moments when you know I
see I see gestures of kindness on the
parts of my kids towards other kids it's
its milestones being hit and I'm not
about numbers in a way you know like
it's when it's just hey you know you did
that thing that you knew was hard but
you still did it anyway you you figure
that out yeah it's it's those things
it's it's uh yeah it's it's the it's the
it's the did we raise it get human not
did we grow he's a good athlete or
whatever so so yeah it's those little
things um let's see domino EEP who shot
JFK [ __ ] I think the cinematographer was
tech Fujimoto maybe uh yeah I don't know
I don't have I don't have DP deep ground
in my head sorry
Domino I wish I knew more strange one
but how would I Wes Pritchard 84 how
would I
reboot the Ghostbusters universe I don't
need one man not everything needs a
universe you know we had one amazing
movie sometimes I'm fine with that
sometimes like that it's never going to
be better than that so we're gonna do it
make it different or don't do it at all
just leave it be my dick so tell
Ghostbusters this to all works still all
works let's see hey Adam are you doing
Mike Morehead 37 what do I think of the
venom trailers I do not need a venom
movie I just don't I you know I I
understand why they're making one
because you know you got to keep the
spider-man IP alive you've got to keep
making movies in that universe to have
the rights to make movies in that
universe but there's there's there's no
part of that character that I'm I'm
enthused by or energized to go out of my
house to go see oh yeah I don't know ah
let's see
but bum bum J he'll love I need one
money encourage you discouraged by the
current pace in which more diverse types
of people get the opportunity to tell
stories from different points of view I
I am encouraged and yet disheartened I'm
encouraged when I get to see things like
crazy rich Asians you know I get to see
oh hey
it's a giant studio motion picture that
is written and directed by an entirely
starring asian-americans or Asian Brits
or Asian actors an Asian talent because
again have to be careful it's in that
Asian American if you're from London
Idris Elba is not african-american FYI
so always I'm always I'm thrilled to see
that stuff because they understand
there's the audience and never doesn't
see it but I'm disheartened when I'm
also on the flip side of that realize
that there have been two other movies in
the last 40 years that have similar
stories better luck tomorrow and and Joy
Luck Club
and and how that's possible given the
fact that there are especially today
when China and Japan are such heavy
audiences for the work that Hollywood
makes that they are not just leaning
into it's like hey let's make more
content for that you know while while
the asian-american population in America
is not as as large as the
african-american population it's still a
robust population it is still a
underserved audience that will happily
show up and happily give you money for
their movies and you know what other
people will too
I feel like progress is happening at a
faster rate that it's ever happened
before but it's still far too slow
because they're still far too far to go
so so yeah I think we're making progress
but not not fast enough Agusta f-93 do I
wear Birkenstocks nope not a hippie
sorry let's see wilt RA wilt burger a
favorite movie aliens I think is still
from me the best may the best movie I've
ever seen it is it is flawless and
nothing about it is dated and everything
about it fires on every cylinder that it
has so so yeah and I do love rent of the
Lost Ark to death let's heat up a
bootblack PP bleep everywhere a one or
films like valerian in the city of a
thousand planets too ambitious to become
the next big thing for a broad audience
I don't think it's ambition I I don't
think ambition is the problem I think
you know because Mad Max fury road is
ambitious as [ __ ] it is the most
ambitious didn't have ever seen and this
is great quote by Steven Soderbergh
where he watched it he says I don't
understand how a dozen people didn't die
every day on that set it is a
mind-blowing piece of cinema and it's
it's ambitious as hell it's giant and
big and
and they went into that without a script
they were they were sort of making it up
visually and telling that story visually
it is nothing but raw uncut ambition I
think the problem with valerian is that
they forgot to to make it a story to
grounded a character you know in a way
that that makes you care about all that
[ __ ] you know if the world is going to
be insane the miss story needs to be
simple and if the story is going to be
insane then the world needs to be simple
but I think that the the viewer can only
hold on to one set of insanity at a time
and and valerian didn't do that you know
I mean valerian is beautiful to look at
but it's not in services very much so I
think if you can figure out a way to do
that then hey you can do whatever the
hell you want but unless you crack that
then bonanno ah let's see
just dual 78 with Game of Thrones having
wrapped the actors when do you think
we'll get the next season the last
season
how excited am I for it I think they've
already given us and released it I think
it's like july 2019 summer 2019 is when
the final season premieres and i'm super
excited for it i love Game of Thrones
even even when I don't love it I still
love it and there's times that you know
I don't love it I don't love everything
but but on the whole I'm a Game of
Thrones fan so and I cannot wait to see
where this ends up and then I will get
to finally go back and read the books
and see where george RR martin would
have had it end up and and get to live
in that sweet duality of two diverging
two diverging paths in the woods
demented six Game six a more gamer what
was my favorite part of being a part of
Castle Rock being on set being on set
and and and getting to feel the awesome
responsibility of having written words
on a page that other people are making
real
and I remember being we were shooting a
lot of nights on my episode and there
was definitely a beat where it's you
know three o'clock in the morning and
we're in the middle of the woods in deep
Massachusetts and it's 40 degrees out
and and I felt guilt and having written
on a page
exterior woods night instead of exterior
woods day and and that's that that guilt
is real let's see what else we've got
what else we got one answer
tangerine Joey what are my thoughts on
the cloak-and-dagger TV show I quite
like the cloak-and-dagger TV show I
wasn't sure at first I'm I haven't seen
the finale yet some only nine into the
10 I feel like the lives of those
teenagers are real and I feel like I
understand who they are and and and I
get all of the dualities of the two of
them it's a show about duality the thing
that lost me for a while was the the
vocabulary of the show was imprecise and
that I didn't know when there was like a
vision or a memory or teleportation and
there were it didn't give me enough cues
as to I'm what am I supposed to feel
about where I am right now and that's a
big thing for a show a show has to teach
you how to watch it it needs to teach
you how to tell how to add a how to
decipher the language of it you know the
wire is weird that way because the wire
was the first show that was that
serialize that was that that ongoing
like no other show had really been as oh
we're not paying off things every
episode that we're gonna set up we're
gonna set a mystery in episode two they
won't pay off until episode eight and
that long throw is part of the joy of
watching a show it was teaching you how
to watch it as it went but I think that
you know cloak and dagger didn't do that
quite as effectively as it should have
early on but by the time it got to the
the the oil rig episode and there was a
six episode where where the the
weirdness of it's the time loop episode
that every science-fiction show does at
some point
that the emotional nature of it paid off
and it dovetails nicely with the sort of
science fiction day traveling and so
like I like those leads I like that
world New Orleans is a really
interesting place to shoot that show
because you get the texture of that city
and it's not also like the popular New
Orleans it's the New Orleans off the
beaten path but yeah like I kind of
liked it I like I like the the this why
a version of Marvel quite a bit like I
like Runaways a lot and I cloak and
dagger or lock so yeah and I like that I
like those two speeds of Marvel TV so
yeah I'm a fan I am a fan
Adam parks 94 what was it like working
with JJ Abrams I have never met JJ
Abrams I think he knows who I am but he
would not recognize me in a crowd so so
yeah someday someday soon my prince will
come I swear to God
let's see it is good man my favorite
part of my bat - when you cast a film a
TV series do I get to sit in or watch
the auditions for the episodes you write
YES on alphas I did and so much of that
stuff is not just coming in on tapes
it's not it's no longer that's due to
the goal
hey here's you know a bunch of people
sitting on the hallway to read for a
role
it is now here's you know eight video
clips you get to watch and say which of
these actors do you think would be best
it is always weird at the beginning of
the show when they're casting the major
roles you know there's depending on the
show like the showrunner could decide I
know who I want or I want to make this
decision alone and then some shows its
hey everybody what do we think about
this who's the best person for that and
that's super fun like I just I have I
have the best time Maryland oh man you
know it'd be the best sheriff that guy
oh yeah he's pretty cool can't get him
but somebody like that would be great
it's a lot of fun
let's see greens from Brazil Ola Ken
Kenny put thy watch orphan black if so
did you like it I watched the first like
three seasons and then I got a little
too confusing for me I loved the first
season the first seeds were all from
black is one of my favorite seasons a TV
because the mystery is so clear that the
characters drive for what she wants is
so clear Who am I who are these other
people who did this to us
like that's that's all fantastic stuff
and Tatiana maslany is I mean that that
is still life one of my favorite
performances ever because it's so
there's so much work and to make that
all real and to make it all distinct
yeah it's it's astonishing the fact that
she never won an Emmy for that is you
know one more reason the VMI's are
ridiculous little wards or ridiculous as
I look at my ink pot which is totally
ridiculous - super evil empire are you a
fan of Avatar The Last Airbender Legend
of Korra [ __ ] yes
Avatar The Last Airbender is for my
money one of the 20 best TV shows ever
made
it is it is doing a thing that kids TV
had never really done before at least
American kids TV it is doing a thing
that most it's it's as deep and as dense
and as rich as game of thrones' it just
happens to have kids in it but it's it's
phenomenal it's phenomenal Zuko is one
of the best villains I've ever seen
there's there's so much I mean [ __ ]
soccer you know like making that
character makes sense he's the the
Xander of Avatar but he's necessary like
it's it's amazing it's amazing it's I
discovered that that Nickelodeon had
been rerunning them all recently so I
just said the DVR for it and have been
just wallowing in the glory of nothing
but avatar for the last couple of weeks
let's see and also super evil empire
his animation like that a better medium
for a lone wolf and cub than a TV series
now I want to see I want to go to fuel
Japan I want to get like an amazing cast
of Japanese actors and I I want to do
that for real I want to see lone wolf
and cub for real
Michael JW Jones every barbecue sauce we
didn't raise let's see everywhere 0:01
any story left to tell for the matrix
franchise I'm sure there is I don't know
what that is because you know much like
Star Wars you know as we know what Star
Wars is about the Skywalker family there
has to have more story than that but I
don't know what that looks like yet
there have to be more stories in that
universe than me oh so I'm not sure what
that is I think there's totally like a
prequel with Michael B Jones as Morpheus
and what that is like what what it's
like realizing you know that you are
your destiny is to find Jesus and to
turn away from that calling to embrace
that call and all that stuff yeah I
think that's that's that's up there
Fifty Shades of plague cream they're
crunchy peanut butter creamy man [ __ ]
that yeah
Charlotte 42 42 42 I'm put in charge of
DC films what do you do I hire amazing
filmmakers I hire amazing field makers
who have stories they want to tell I
empower them to tell those stories i
liberate them from the necessity to tell
a universe let's just find a great story
I think I think trying to compete at
this level at this stage what Marvel is
a mistake
so find find your own path because it
can't also be that path
are the best people get out of their way
is is I think the key let's see
family duty calls from the real dark
night how do i best man his family work
life I probably don't do it very well
because I think I end up sacrificing is
my own stuff so it's the work is 9 to 6
family is you know 7 to 11 and then the
work again is like 11:30 to 1 and there
was precious little time for me to do
anything else for myself which I need to
figure out a way to do but yeah that's
that everywhere is there one again can
films based on video games work
absolutely I think that the problem is
you need to divorce the game experience
from the film experience I've seen far
too many video game movies where they
try to give you the same feel like oh no
now we're gonna slip in the first person
oh no now we're gonna do this thing oh
no now she's gonna dog and swim a little
too guns that is not ultimately what
will make it work it's what about this
character is interesting what about this
world is interesting and then how do you
make those things dovetail it is not
about fighting the same bosses is not
about you know the same mechanics it is
about making the best movie you can Dan
Lee comics do I struggle with depression
anxiety disorders and if so how do I
manage a creative workload on top of
that I am I am blessed that I do not
struggle with depression anxiety
disorders I struggle with impostor
syndrome which is I I you know I am NOT
any good at this every day I get up and
I try to write and it's not working the
way I think it should be working
and everybody will find out that I'm
just a fraud and a charlatan and they
will bust me and fire me and then I will
go back to doing the things that I don't
want to do that's different from
depression and anxiety for sure and they
are in no way in the same league so I
have nothing but empathy for people you
know and nothing but admiration for
people who managed to wrestle those
demons even temporarily into submission
in order for them to get on with the
process of making good stuff
but I am NOT one of those people let's
see
bum-bum-bum hayden Hayes Pugh one of the
differences between writing a script for
a comic versus a television series comic
scripts are the hardest things in the
world I've ever written because if
you're writing a TV show or a movie a
there's a format to follow and that
format is immutable you know a
screenplay looks like a screenplay
teleplay looks like a teleplay those
beats are the same and and you can kind
of diagnose what that looks like there
is no one set format for comic book
script so you could read a dozen of them
and they'll all be different and you
know you get from the the giant biblical
tomes that Alan Moore rights for his
artists or Neil Gaiman right for their
artists to the crazy sparse
just like you know tone poems that but
some others you know writers will write
you got to find your own path for how it
best makes sense for you and just the
math of comic book writing is harder you
know like you're you are not just in a
screenplay I can write you know Timmy
gets out of his car walks up to the
front door rings the bell somebody
answers julie answers the door and and
they kiss and walk inside and they start
[ __ ] i can write that on a page and
that is all the thing that a
cinematographers their right well the
camera's gonna move and we're gonna
follow this all it's two or three shots
but you know whatever or can just be one
shot one single camera move can convey
all of that in comics you can't be
motion there's no way to do Tim gets out
of his car walks up the stairs rings the
bell the door opens and he kisses a girl
how many pounds is that a panel is a
still image so how many pounds do you
need to tell that story how many how
many can you do it in and in two or
three long shots is it all super tight
close-ups you know some of that is the
artists responsibility of course but you
as the writer still need to tell to give
a roadmap to give a little bit of a
blueprint you know it's it is it is so
hard to realize that you as
the writer have to dissect and and and
display in tiny fractions of time your
your your choosing the pictures you're
gonna tell and then once you do that
it's alright well know how many balloons
is on this page how many words fit in a
balloon then it becomes math in a weird
way it is it is all of the the problems
of dramaturgy plus and Mitaka fee plus
arithmetic it's really hard to do I love
its death but it's hard to do let's see
um the let Hill cable television came
with a formula every commercial break
had a reveal or cliffhanger in an
episode and wrapped up the story does
Netflix and Amazon TV shows suffer from
not having this there's no greater bane
in the life of the television writer and
false jeopardy and that is all that
commercial breaks do is not just cable
TV LS the network TV thing I mean
network TV exists because it had been
sponsored by you know tied or General
Mills the Ford Playhouse Theatre
presents Henry Fonda in Gunsmoke or
whatever commercial breaks commercials
are the reason why television exists
cable TV pay cable TV premium cable TV
gets away with not having commercials by
charging you upfront and in making you
pay for that stuff but you know the
every eight minutes you have to create
some false jeopardy in order to
quote-unquote
retain the viewer from not changing
channels that much false jeopardy is
hard to do because it's always false
because you know your hero is not going
to die in the middle of the show you
know the mystery is not gonna get solved
that the culprit of the murder is not
gonna get caught in act 3 that's just
not the way to your that's no way
stories work so having to create that
kind of false jeopardy is is is rough to
do the thing the benefit of that the
added buzz of that is it gives you a
rhythm it gives you a a rising and
falling sense of escalation which even
in a premium cable show like Game of
Thrones it still has their still rhythm
to every episode of that show it's not
just 40 minutes of [ __ ] waiting for
five
it's a resolution but you can take more
time with that you can you can lay your
stuff better you can let the drama play
you're gonna have scenes you could have
eight-minute scenes of of you know
[ __ ] Cersei and Tyrion just talking
and it's amazing because these are great
actors doing great work you don't have
to fake your way through it
so I don't think it's a it's a question
of suffering I think it's a question of
different let's see
[Music]
Dean cinematic movie maker do I ever use
elements that I thought were cool from
an abandoned screenplay for a new
screenplay one of one of the first
people I met in Hollywood when I when I
had declared even for myself that I want
to write TV I was gonna in John Rogers
who who at the time was running leverage
and oh man they're giving me a
two-minute countdown the [ __ ] anyway
John said to me use every part of the
Buffalo writers use every part of the
Buffalo if there's a thing you like
there's an action beat that you like
that there's a character you liked
nothing is dead if nobody had ever seen
it before so yeah there's a bunch of
strip mining I've done to old stuff to
bring it on to new stuff
yeah let's say Domino EP ever listened
to fish now that man I need songs trying
to find a question that I haven't been
asked wander waiter tots how long do I
think the MCU should go I think every
story needs an end I think the story the
visit of an end is a story that nobody
ultimately wants to listen to or to see
or to watch how long that should go
I'm not sure I don't know what the
stories are after infinity war I don't
know how many different ways you can
pull this taffy but but it needs an end
nothing can go on in perpetuity and have
it be emotionally resonant and have it
deliver the kind of emotional physical
just spiritual resonance you needed to
if there's no ending something it needs
to um I think this might have to be it
guys got 30 seconds to wrap up this will
not be the last time I do this because
it was kind of fun so listen for a fat
man on Batman I have been mark barnard
in my office talking about Castle Rock
and Treadstone
and writing and barbecue and all the all
amazing things stay tuned next week same
time same fat channel SModcast calm or
youtube.com slash Kevin Smith peace out
you guys
[Music]
[Applause]
you